is this the cutest game of hide-and-seek
ever are devarone Ian's impervious to
flame throwers and mando is Jar Jar
confirmed maybe he's a Gungan yes its
episode 6 of the Mandalorian and
together we're gonna break down the
episode uncover all those Easter eggs
and theorize what might be in store for
our helmet clad antihero you're gonna
want to stick around till the end of the
video as I'll be going over some of the
cameos you may have missed
Moff Gideon's appearance next episode
and what Zero's witnessing of the
hologram might mean for the Mandalorian
so let's get into it
after the Mandalorians adventure on
Tatooine mando sets his sight on his
next job he's been in talks with an old
acquaintance by the name of ran ironic
since mando is on the run back in the
day ran and mando used to pull jobs
together and it just so happens ran has
some work for the Mandalorian well
really he just needs mando for his ship
since it's both off the Imperial and New
Republic grid systems making it
difficult to detect he even refers to
the ship as a ghost ran operates his own
syndicate out of this Cloud City looking
like ship but it's interesting to note
here that it was mando who actually
reached out to ran this is interesting
since it kind of hints that the
Mandalorian doesn't really have a plan
for the child as of this episode he
hasn't expressed any interest in finding
out who this child really is who wants
him or ways in which they can get their
bounty hunters guild off their tail for
reasons L hint at later on in the video
I think that's soon to change
turns out one of Rands associates got in
trouble with some competitors and got
himself caught it'll be up to mando and
a ragtag group of four other mercenaries
to bust him out the only problem is that
ran never mentioned that the Razr crest
was part of the deal the Razer crest
which hides the child but ran is quick
to note that mando needs him more than
the other way around ran knows mandos
wanted by the bounty hunters guild so
getting work isn't as easy as it used to
be were then introduced to the leader of
the group mayfield played by comedian
bill burr you know I'm afraid of robots
he's a former Imperial sharpshooter who
gets offended at even the slight
implication he may have been a
stormtrooper wasn't
Stormtrooper wiseass because we all know
how bad stormtrooper aim is me Feld will
act as the trigger man fitting since he
has this cool back mounted blaster which
can fire while taking cover immediately
there is some animosity between him and
mando as we'll find out later this is
all a setup to trap the Mandalorian and
there are even some clues that hint at
it like when they're about to get off
the ship and we seem a failed ng on
having their own private talk
speaking of Gian she's the first
speaking twi'lek we've seen on the show
so far you may remember the actress who
plays her as Tonks from Harry Potter or
OSHA from Game of Thrones apparently her
and mando have some romantic history not
sure how that works since he's never
taken off his helmet they last worked
together on a mission gone wrong on Al's
Hawk 3 Al's Hawk is an ice planet home
to the tau species these dudes
apparently something went wrong on the
mission with the Mandalorians saying he
had to do what he needed to do in order
to finish the job as will later find out
this likely had something to do with
leaving jion's brother behind the
prisoner the episodes title is referring
to for G on the mission is in business
it's personal while prepping for the
mission Mayfield remarks that mandos
ship looks like a Kanto bite slot
machine Kanto bite being the coastal
city found on kin Tonica which you may
remember houses several casinos featured
in the last Jedi we're also introduced
to burg a Deveraux nyan mailed ever
onehans are known for their protruding
horns their species even have two livers
which make them more resistant to
poisons and carcinogens oh they also
have black blood the last team member is
a droid by the name of zero we've seen
in episode one and five mandos distrust
of droids likely because his parents
were killed by them as zero preps for
the mission he unlocks a distorted
version of the message mando received
from grief carga in Episode three this
message has nothing to do with the plot
of the episode and is our biggest clue
as to what's to come in future episodes
as we know from the trailers the
Mandalorian and grief meet yet again
before the season is done on IMDb the
description for next episode says
in old rival extends an invitation for
the Mandalorian to make peace is this
old rival grief
Mayfield goes over the mission they'll
use the razor crest to gain access to a
fortified transport prison ship run by
the New Republic remember the New
Republic seems to be the main force in
charge of the galaxy at the moment after
the fall of the Empire manda was lied to
their prisoner wasn't captured by a
rival syndicate rather the New Republic
something he doesn't want to be involved
with since he's supposed to be keeping a
low profile mando is continually lied
through throughout the episode leading
to his team members eventually
backstabbing him it's kind of funny that
the Mandalorian says he doesn't trust
droids but it's non droids who've been
the ones who've really backstabbed him
you know I don't trust anybody enroute
to the mission bird finds mandos weapon
cache which the Mandalorian doesn't take
too kindly to they tussle accidentally
opening up the child's hiding spot none
of them seem to know who or what this
creature is Mei failed mistaking it for
a pet at the end of the episode the fact
that the Mandalorian doesn't kill his
backstabbing crew members rather
imprisons them on the ship could mean
they might make a reappearance and the
fact they know of the child's existence
could help justify that we'll keep that
in the back of our minds for now Xero
performs a succession of quick maneuvers
in order to couple the razor crest to
the transport ship undetected but I
swear to God as soon as may fell drop
baby Oda I was like kill him manda manda
opens the hatch and takes one last look
at where the child is showing us he
cares through the prison hallways we
catch a glimpse of some of the prisoners
including this dude who looks like he
could be a former Imperial and our
dannion like Ryo from solo and even a
cameo from sloth Burk shoots a MSE six
series repair droid we've seen them
before in the original trilogy this
alerts these security droids who if you
check out their armor have the New
Republic logo emblazoned on it and leave
it up to mando to completely destroy
these droids using a combination of all
his weapons and gadgets
[Music]
like these other dudes don't even help
them and baby drop her bill over here is
like make sure you clean up your mess
zero detects an organic signature on the
ship but it's too late we have a new
republic guard here played by Matt
Lanter who some may recognize as the
voice of Anakin Skywalker in the Clone
Wars he's holding a tracking beacon
which if pressed could alert the new
Republic now the Mandalorian doesn't
want to kill him giving us more insight
into his character but of course Shion
is like screw that and off some of one
of her throwing knives with the beacon
tracker pressed the team is only 20
minutes to acquire the prisoner and get
the hell out of there and Berg goes all
Hulk on some of the security droids
smash finally they reached the prisoner
jion's brother Quinn who the Mandalorian
apparently left behind on one of their
old missions the others trap mando in
the cell with all his gadgets bad move
guys bad move he ends up using his whip
cord to latch on to a security droid
ripping off its arm and using it to
escape mandos escape allows him to
access the controls to stop the others
from reaching the ship as well as cut
off communication with zero the rest of
the episode plays out like the movie
alien with mando systematically hunting
down the rest of the mercenaries as they
all split up the lovely brother-sister
relationship between Quinn and Gian is a
lie too with Quinn telling Mei failed he
basically doesn't care if she makes it
back on the ship or not eventually mando
tracks Quinn down where Quinn first
appeals to the bounty hunters pockets by
saying he'll make sure his reward is
received and more but when that doesn't
seem to work Quinn appeals to his sense
of honour
apparently the Mandalorians code
dictates that once he takes on a job he
must see it through killing Quinn would
be a violation of this code
back on the ship in one of my favorite
scenes of the episode that child is
discovered by zero and the child is no
dummy
he knows that zero is on his way to off
him so he puts up his hand to use his
force power and
actually it's the mandalorian the razor
crest takes off from the transport ship
and travels at light speed back to ran
syndicate we see that the Mandalorian is
indeed a man of honor returning the
prisoner to ran and receiving his reward
ran asks about the others but mando says
no questions asked
that's the policy right with the mission
now over the Mandalorian heads back to
the ship but ran and quinn have other
plans ran unleashes a gunship with
orders to take down manda and that's
probably what would happen if it weren't
for the new republic tracking beacon he
left on Quinn the same one he got from
Davin that new republic guard this
device leads a small squadron of X
Fighters right to them fun fact the
three pilots here are david fellow need
Ebro Chow and Rick family wha who have
all directed episodes of the Mandalorian
seeing the gunship they opened fire
blasting the crap out of ran ship yet we
never do find out if ran and Quinn
survived back on the razor crest the
Mandalorian and child are reunited with
a fun callback to episode 3 when the
Mandalorian gave the child the ball back
to play with we also see that Berg may
failed ng on have been locked away with
Berg having a major headache from those
blaster doors being smashed in on him as
I suggested earlier I think the biggest
clue to what will happen next episode is
how zero was fiddling around with that
grief carga hologram perhaps he
communicated to grief without our
knowledge or somehow activated something
whereby grief can now find mandos
location either way it looks like the
Mandalorian will be headed back to
navarro the planet we saw in episodes 1
& 3 or at least a planet that looks a
heck of a lot like it I believe this is
also where we'll meet Giancarlo Esposito
'he's character moth Gideon if you look
on IMDB under G and Carlos name you'll
see it says he makes an appearance in
chapter 7 so my best guess is that
either the Mandalorian will be tricked
by grief in order to get the child to
moth Gideon or simply that moth Gideon
has somehow tracked the child down and
gets in the way of whatever business
grief in the Mandalorian have either way
the introduction of moth Gideon will
likely shed some light on who exactly
wants the child why they want him and
start laying the foundation for season 2
while also giving us some much-needed
answers for this season I also think
it's fair to assume as we later see
mando chasing moth and a ship that moth
does acquire the child whether or not
mando gets some back isn't certain
we still have one episode to go after
the next one but whatever happens I'm
sure it'll be a wild ride also be sure
to put in your calendars that the next
episode comes out this Wednesday thanks
for watching everyone I hope you'll give
this video a like and subscribe comment
below what you think of the show so far
and if you have any theories on where
the show might be headed I'd love to
hear them there too you can also follow
me on twitter at big story YT until next
time remember I have spoken